Awesome.
The,
the life that you were living,
you could probably pull those dark thoughts out like other people.
Well,
which probably can't sit in a bar man and uh,
write stuff down.
And uh,
the next day I'd pick it up,
go,
oh my God,
what the fuck was I thinking?
You know?
And it just horrified me.
But yeah,
sometimes you can pull dark stuff at a bad moment in the life.
Well you had experiences.
I mean,
I mean it's just trying to kill yourself with pills or whatever the fuck you
were doing.
I mean know the darkness that you had in your life.
Like my sister being murdered and shit and my mother,
my mother was a 12 year old girl and her mother was dating my father.
Her mother was
my grandmother passed,
my father left that and went into a 12 year old who girls room and raped her.
That's me.
That's how I got started.
And then later in life raping,
my sister did not know it,
you know,
he raped another daughter and not know it.
Always heard whispering.
So people whispering and even in the evil item.
And what the fuck's your problem?
They're not getting the ring with somebody that,
that knew my dad and they beat the fucking shit out of me because they hated him
because they'd seen some of the shit that he did.
You want to believe that of your own father?
I want to believe that.
God,
you don't want to believe that Dee.
I was the girl that you met earlier.
Cody.
She is a first daughter of mine that I held in my lap.
She was 2122 before I would ever pick up.
One of my daughters said that my,
my lap
because I was afraid.
I turned into my father.
No,
never wanted that.
And everyone,
he's someone that abused a child cause I didn't and I knew what the shit was
like and I knew what I did to my fucking head
getting right and getting sober
warning to talk about it helps a lot.
It makes it better.
You don't cure it,
you know you never get over it,
but I can deal with it now.
I don't have to go medicate when it,
now when you talk to these people that you're also helping your medium that also
have these problems.
How many of them have also been abused?
A lot.
A Lot,
man.
You know what it's like to be sitting at a comicon and a look out there and
there's people in your line and your eye contact contacts.
A kid,
he looked at the kid and they look at you and you're like,
for a mother Fucker,
you're going through it too,
aren't ya?
And I can tell it.
I know that putting kids,
being sexually abused,
he can see it.
And I hate that feeling because then they get up to the front and you're like
trying to talk to them and they're like,
shut down.
Completely.
Yeah.
And then the fucking asshole is next to him was probably doing the bullshit.
He's wanting my contention,
man.
What chance did I have him getting in good attention and not much.
I keep going back to the kid.
How can you tell?
He's just feeling,
you know it,
you smell it,
taste it.
If you see the fear,
you know,
and you see the way that the dad communicates with them and you see their
reaction and they won't look at you with their eyes,
you know,
really hard to get him look at him.
He really is.
And No,
I remember I told somebody one time that probably the one thing that helped me
in my early life about going through all that sexual abuse and bullshit was I
learned that a lot at a very young age,
regional.
I learned that a lot of these,
cause it helped me get me to a safe place,
you know,
uh,
I learned to judge people in their attitudes.
You know,
I knew what buttons to push and what buttons not to push with my stepmother and
I knew what was a safe place and if there were key words that come out from her,
I knew to fucking go hide.
I had to start reading this shit.
Then I had to start coming up with storylines and stuff to get me out of shit.
So I wouldn't be put into the position to get gotten again.
When you're earning that should have 12 and 13.
Brother,
you're getting some fucking knowledge,
but it's a motherfucker man.
You know,
just to have to go through it and uh,
I don't know brother.
I mean if there was ever a reason to,
uh,
bring back the big one,
the gas or bullets or whatever aim.
I think paintings perfect for anybody.
That'd be just kids.
It was make a public fucking,
hey,
fuck five years in jail.
Fuck you motherfucker.
But you dancing on the end of a rope that would get people's attention when you
might stop some of it.
Yeah.
I don't know how to steal.
What would they do that would stop it completely,
but it's,
it's one of the most disturbing characteristics of people that,
that,
that that's even possible.
Buddy wants to talk,
nobody wants to talk about that kid damn shirt
because here's what happens to the kid.
Nine Times out of 10,
they raise their hand and they say something.
Then this group comes in,
this group jumps in,
cops come in and they say this ashes that late,
he's probably just exaggerating this,
that this that you have to go home with them.
Oh Fuck No.
You can't put that kid back in that house.
Right.
What chance do you have now?
Or you up in an orphanage where you're eating raped again?
Yeah.
Who Does?
Who wants to all these share at an orphanage more than a predator.
And that's the other problem is a lot of kids that get abused like that.
One of abusing other
kids.
Absolutely.
Even what you're taught
Sandusky at that whole charity for kids.
I was this whole like thing map.
Yeah.
I'm going to open up abuse children's home.
That way I know where to go get one.
Yup.
Knew that the kids were damaged and they would be used to it.
You know what we,
what we call love.
It can be an a and luckily you know sometimes the kid looks to get his ass
kicked because that's the only type of loving knows.
That's true.
You're a powerful man to have gone through all this and to be able to express
it.
So honestly,
two to everybody,
I mean that,
that,
that is an amazing thing because the pain of your experiences has not stopped
you from expressing all of the,
all of the downsides of it,
but also that you've come out of it on the other end in a very positive way.
I mean you're a great guy to be around your funniest shit.
You,
you have amazing stories and you're clean.
Now
colonial.
I know I'm funny in a room like this,
but go,
there's not any competition.
Come on Joe.
Me Fuck.
Where do you go from here?
You know lapdog 27 no,
that's amazing.
Just one really is I just want to help somebody else feel what I felt.
Yeah.
Cause I don't want them to have to do the things that I did to quit feeling
cause I'll tell you man,
it's just a whole lot easier to pick up cocaine and forget about it than it is
to go through counseling.
Go through this,
go through reliving it 25 fucking times.
You know,
you go into counseling and then they say,
okay,
tell us exactly how it happened.
Do I really fucking want to do that?
Right.
What do you want me to do that so you can get it over there and Jack off of
what?
What's your none on this cause that's what we're thinking.
What do you want me to remember it?
I want to fuck fucking forget it.
Tell me how it forget it.
Don't tell me how to remember it.
I got it down.
What was ultimately,
what was ultimately the thing that allowed you to stay clean when you had
faltered five or six times,
whatever it was,
what was ultimately the thing that allowed you to get past all this and just to
embrace a bride
being healthy?
I think it was just
realizing that I wasn't going to fail this time
and that game from Dallas not giving up on me.